[Música]
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su cita con
la actualidad francesa con las pantallas
de france 24 el cómic y la guerra en
ucrania siguen afectando la vida
cotidiana de los franceses inflación
escasez de turistas falta de mano de
obra son algunas de las consecuencias de
estas crisis de ello hablaremos en este
capítulo y terminaremos en alto
visitando un hermoso castillo francés
vamos
[Música]
la inflación sigue su curva ascendente
en francia en abril llegó casi un 5% un
récord desde 1985 los productos que más
han aumentado de precio son los
manufacturados los servicios y la
alimentación por eso en el país de la
gastronomía los franceses han comenzado
a modificar su dieta
soy un jugador
es verdad frente al aumento de los
precios los franceses sonríen menos a la
hora de hacer las compras en el mercado
del prado en marsella se dedican más
bien a buscar las ofertas como la luz
aquí los calabacines están bajando de
precio pero están muy caros entre los
pasillos muchas familias de bajos
recursos y jubilados que han debido
modificar su lista de la compra en coche
pos tengo una pequeña pensión así que
tengo que poner atención no es la misma
vida que hace seis meses
yo con mi pequeña jubilación antes vivía
y podía hasta ayudar a mis hijos pero
ahora me toca racionaron entrenando y
formación incluso el vendedor de pollos
a las brasas nunca había visto una
situación parecida
es más complicado a nivel de las tarifas
la mercadería está más cara así que se
vende menos uno siente que hay una
restricción a nivel del presupuesto
familiar
el mismo ambiente se siente en este
mercado parisino los clientes dicen
constatar un aumento de precios y muchos
han decidido consumir de manera
diferente
por ejemplo ya no compro carne prefiero
llevar huevos salchicha palitos de
surimi
ya no somos grandes comedores de carne
podemos no comer carne o comer una vez
por semana
y algunos no sólo ahorran en la comida
y muchísima angustia
según el instituto de estadísticas el
consumo de los hogares ha disminuido en
un 15 por ciento
[Música]
la gran dimisión esta renuncia masiva de
trabajadores que se produjo en eeuu tras
la crisis del hobbit se ha reproducido a
menor escala en francia en julio del año
pasado hubo un récord de renuncia y eso
que al mismo tiempo el desempleo se
encuentra en mínimos históricos un
sector especialmente afectado es el de
la hostelería y la restauración donde
las duras condiciones de trabajo siguen
sin atraer a quienes buscan empleo
80 cubiertos por día este restaurante
está lleno cada mediodía en terraza y en
sala
pero tiene un problema ha sido imposible
encontrar un cocinero para hacer las
entradas y los postres para salir del
paso el dueño llamó a uno de sus amigos
de nueva york que le ayuda durante un
mes
y yo me llamo y vine y hoy es mi último
día
más
atrás el ambiente relajado el
responsable no oculta su preocupación
hace dos meses que buscamos se ha vuelto
una urgencia pero lo conseguiremos lo
asoció hoy los restaurantes no son
atractivos para los trabajadores después
de dos años de crisis sanitaria los
empleados han abandonado este sector se
quejan de los ritmos de trabajo y los
horarios desfasados él intenta seducir a
través de las redes sociales con días de
descanso extra y mejor repartidos nos
pusimos un anuncio proponiendo tres días
y medio de trabajo por semana a jornada
completa eso es muy bueno para el sector
de la restauración y no hemos tenido
respuestas
esta escasez de mano de obra afecta a
todo un sector se teme que durante la
temporada estival 300.000 puestos queden
vacantes
en este restaurante montpellier faltan
dos camareros y dos personas en la
cocina ha habido candidaturas pero no se
han concretado y la gente me dice ahí
estaré y nunca viene y si vienen les
proponemos hacer una prueba pero luego
no se presentan
desde el 1 de abril los salarios han
aumentado en un 16% un argumento que
parece todavía insuficiente para
convencer a los candidatos
[Música]
los turistas están volviendo a francia
primer destino mundial en el año 2019
sin embargo china cada vez más confinada
y rusia- en guerra siguen frenando la
recuperación de un sector esencial para
la economía francesa
parís como no la veíamos hace meses los
barcos del sena llenos de turistas
y en los grandes almacenes visitantes
del mundo entero
[Música]
sin embargo siguen ausentes los turistas
chinos y rusos en el 2019 representaban
un 2 por ciento de los visitantes en
francia pero un 6 por ciento de los
ingresos del sector más de 3 mil
millones de euros
en el jardín del castillo deball y vi
conté al sureste de parís su ausencia se
siente a diario este monumento es
visitado sobre todo por extranjeros 10%
de los visitantes son chinos
manchado las excepciones al echar afuera
tenemos un marco excepcional con los
jardines el bosque y la arquitectura del
edificio
hay muchos turistas extranjeros que lo
privatiza como las aves jorge moore
[Música]
de excepción es un castillo de tarjeta
postal por el que algunos pagaban
centenas de miles de euros para casarse
allí y por ahora estas imágenes forman
parte del pasado
a causa del cob y desde marzo del 2019
en que no ha habido una boda aquí quizá
los próximos matrimonios en el lugar en
octubre de este año son una fuente de
ingresos irremplazable para este sitio
monumental los eventos privados
representan un 12 por ciento de sus
ingresos
la crisis sanitaria hizo huir a los
chinos primero y desde febrero la guerra
en ucrania ha alejado a los rusos en la
costa azul decenas de yates siguen
amarrados y bloqueados en este puerto en
tiempo normal es uno de cada tres es
alquilado por rusos pero hoy no hay
ninguna reserva el gerente trata de
atraer nuevos clientes y mantenerse
tranquilo unitario y posee que otras 11
día sigue el curso podemos dudar de que
la guerra es algo serio que va a durar
si usted me viene a ver en julio quizás
no tendré este optimismo nacional nos
han disco estas ausencias dejan pérdidas
financieras difíciles de compensar
seguros profesionales en el 2019 francia
fue la primera destinación turística
mundial con 90 millones de visitantes
extranjeros
[Música]
el río leo ir en el centro de francia
famoso por sus castillos esparcidos en
sus riberas y afluentes la mayoría
construidos durante el renacimiento
francés sin embargo uno de ellos se
vuelve especialmente hermoso en
primavera descubra por qué
durante algunos días en primavera el rey
en el castillo de cheverny es el tulipán
estas flores bailan al ritmo del viento
y forman una alfombra multicolor de 250
metros de largo
son 250.000 bulbos que han sido
plantados a mano uno tras otro por el
jardinero en jefe del castillo y sus
equipos
para que florezcan al mismo tiempo elige
como piensan los bulbos pero también
maneja al detalle los cuidados del suelo
y el suelo tiene que tener un buen
drenaje que evacúe el exceso de agua
pero que guarde una cierta humedad allí
está el secreto del tulipán y su
florecimiento pero tampoco le voy a dar
la receta porque es un secreto que
guardamos muy bien
más de un mes de trabajo en otoño para
apenas dos semanas de flores nada de
riego artificial ni fertilizantes o
pesticidas es una verdadera obra de arte
natural
guau
esta tradición de cheverny anuncia desde
hace nueve años la llegada de la
primavera y si los tulipanes florecen
las visitas aumentan con jerry jones o
late un apenas sale el sol las personas
nos visitan este fin de semana tuvimos
una afluencia récord un 50% más alta de
lo habitual
como las flores duran poco los fanáticos
de los tulipanes tienen apenas algunos
días para visitar este famoso castillo
de la lora y su jardín multicolor
y hasta aquí este capítulo de francia-
en foco gracias por habernos acompañado
y hasta pronto por las pantallas de
france 24 y en france 24 punto com